whether you're nervous about the bad
economy and the rising rate of crime are
you just looking for a good box cutter
wire it has just what you need
this one's excellent this one's just
so-so and this one over here is
dangerously bad this is the knife that I
think is dangerously bad now this is the
Victorinox Sentinel and it's the
one-handed opening version of the
Sentinel
this one has two really big flaws one is
it's very hard to open and it's very
hard to close to get it closed you gotta
press on this little liner lock here
right where it says press and it's a
little stiff and unfortunately that puts
your finger exactly in the path of the
closing blade so you got to remember to
pull your finger out opening with two
hands is not a problem but opening with
one using this little hole here is
actually really tricky because the hinge
is very stiff so it's hard to get open
in a smooth move the Gerber remix is a
pretty good knife although it's not the
best one that we tested this summer what
I really like about this knife is it's
got this cool open design you can kind
of see through it and it's an all-metal
handle and it's got this unusual hole
right here in the middle which is meant
for your index finger so as you grip the
knife it kind of gives you a more
positive grip feels really nice in the
hand and the blade is very effective and
useful it's cool unfortunately it's not
the easiest knife in the world to open
you can open it with one hand but it
takes some practice and it sticks a
little bit it's not the smoothest knife
in the world the best knife in Wired
summer test roundup is the benchmade 551
grip Tilian and i think it's called that
because it's got this really grippy
textured plastic molded handle which
actually does make it really easy to
hold in your hand it's got a great feel
it's very lightweight and best of all
it's extremely smooth opening so you can
open it with one hand like that which is
cool or you can do this cool Boy Scout
trick where you undo the lock and flip
it open like that